happens that changes a person. Even if
one big major sin were to occur, the
person is still very likely to repent to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and to return to the path of Allah
because that is not that person's
environment.
Off of the path of Allah is not that
person's world. However,
a million little steps
and each time we take that extra step,
he reassures us, it's just one step.
It's just one time. It's not that big a
deal. You can go back anytime you want
until before we know it, we have lost
sight of the path of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. till some have been led so far
away from that path that they don't even
know where to start to look for it
again.
And so Allah Subhanahu Waaala tells us
time and time again
do not follow the footsteps of a shan
one step at a time. And that is how he
takes men and women off of his off of
the path of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
However,
in spite of understanding that that a
person may step off of the path of Allah
and put distance between himself and the
path of Allah with repentance, they may
reverse that process entirely.
With repentance, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala revives that once dead or very
hard heart.
But we have to understand that this is
also a process. A person's heart may be
back on the path of Allah, but it is
going to take time for their body and
for the rest of their environment to
follow suit.
So how do we repent?
How do we go back to the path of Allah?
Allah subhanahuaala
tells us
he tells us subhanahua
repent and return fully to Allah
in the most sincere and complete of
ways.
Why do we fail at repentance?
One of the main reasons people fail in
their repentance
is because they have not placed their
reliance upon Allah in repenting.
They placed their reliance on their own
self.
Our prophet sallall.aii wasallam used to
make dua every day and night.
Oh Allah,
do not place me as a sole disposer of my
own affairs even for the blink of an eye
ever,
ever.
Because if a person is left in charge of
his own self
without Allah's guidance and protection,
then the person
has been placed
at the mercy of an ignorant, weak,
shortsighted
creature
that often times we don't even know
what's good for us. neither in the
moment nor in the future or the long
run.
Allah tells us that the human being
makes dua and praise for his own
for his own failure and for his own harm
with the fervance of his same prayer.
the same prayer that he makes fervently
for his own good. We're making dua for
something. We want it. We have that
fervor. We have that vehements. But
really what we are actually asking for
something that is bad for us and we
don't even know the difference.
And so
the human being is not to ever look at
himself as a source of strength in this
way. Never.
And I know this goes against what
society around us has taught us. Those
of us who have grown up in America
especially and now it has reached and
has wrapped its tentacles even around
the minds of those in the far east. That
is you have to have confidence.
You have to have self-esteem.
You have to believe in yourself.
You have to reach inside and pull out
that strength. Where is that strength
coming from? Well, you know, it is like
the
ever paradoxical
pulling oneself up by his own
bootstraps.
Ever imagine that? Going to grab my own
bootstraps. I'm going to lift myself in
the air with my own bootstraps. How?
I'm going to bring the strength from
within.
Where's the strength from within going
to come from? I'm going to bring it from
without. It's a paradox circular
reasoning.
A person is not able to make himself
more powerful or weaker.
We draw our strength and our resolve
from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. When a
person repents,
if they try and attempt to repent
by relying on their own selves for this
repentance, they're going to fail. And
not only will they fail, but they will
continue to fail until a shan brings you
to your knees.
Until you finally just say, "This is who
I am. I might as well embrace it."
A person is not to place his reliance in
himself
ever, but especially not in repentance.
A person places his reliance in Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala. Now this
is where the rubber meets the road. Why?
Because deep down many people are afraid
to do this. Why?
Because there are whispers in his heart.
There are whispers of doubt,
whispers of fears of rejection.
What if Allah lets me down? What if
Allah rejects my repentance? What if
Allah etc. These whispers may even get
so bad that they will cause a person to
question even Allah's existence.
This is not abnormal. This is not
something that the companions of did not
experience. They all experienced that.
Those are the beginning stages of belief
really in the grand scheme of things.
Whispers that, those are the first
steps in a very long journey.
Not until a person gives himself over
entirely,
has the courage to allow himself to free
fall
and to embrace entirely Allah's fate,
Allah's destiny,
and to allow himself
to be caught and supported entirely by
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. No more
doubts. In spite of the doubts, in spite
of the reservations,
in spite of the what-ifs. And if a
person does this, their repentance
will be accepted by Allah.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has made
promises in the Quran.
And we are to look for those promises
and take those promises literally and
very much to heart
because when a person relies upon Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala entirely
impossible that this person will fail
never
will Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala ALLOW A
servant of his who calls out to him, who
raises his hands to the heavens,
will he ever subhanahu
allow those hands to go back down to the
earth empty.
And so a person must learn to trust
Allah.
A person must learn to give up himself.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
he tells us, "Oh you who have believed,
enter into Islam entirely."
Entirely meaning an entire people, but
entirely meaning all of each individual
person. All of you, your money, your
reputation, your body, your heart, your
mind, everything is to enter into Islam.
There is something for it in Islam.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
came to the messenger of Allah.
Wasam
as mentioned by Abdullahbus.
Abdullahbus a companion of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. He narrates to us
that a man asked the messenger of Allah.
Wasam saying,
[Silence]
A man asked the messenger of Allah.
Wasam. He said, "Oh messenger of Allah,
I find it very difficult
to keep
track and to
adopt all of the rulings of Islam.
He found that there were so many
laws or so many new things coming
at him at once that he didn't feel like
he knew where to start.
And so he said, "Tell me one thing that
I should start with and focus on
entirely
and hold to that if I fulfill this one
thing and if I perfect it first, the
rest will fall into place."
And so the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
said,
"Make it so that your tongue is always
moist or wet with the remembrance of
Allah." So here this man asked for one
thing, that first domino that would
cause that effect that would cause the
rest of the dominoes to fall. What is
that one thing? He commanded him with
the remembrance of Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala at all times.
Every time every moment that a person
remembers himself, he is remembering
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. If a person
holds to this,
every time you remember Allah, Allah
will remember you. And if you
remember Allah in yourself, Allah will
remember you in himself.
And if you mention Allah amongst the
people, he will mention you amongst a
greater
set of company.
And so Allah is always more generous
than his servants.
So the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam commanded him with this one
thing
and if we find ourselves at that
crossroads
don't try to do everything all at once
start where Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
started in the Quran one thing at a time
reverse those steps until you find
yourself back on the path of Allah
entirely Islamus.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Allahbar
ill.
[Silence]
ill
Stand shouldertosh shoulder. Close all
of the gaps.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
A means
[Silence]
for
me.
forboly.
[Silence]
Hamidel.
Allah
Allah.
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
Holy.
Amen.
for
[Silence]
Allah.
Say Allah.
Allahbar.
[Silence]
Allahbel
So
Allah
[Silence]
Allah.
Brothers and sisters, assalamu alaykum.
Assalamu alaykum. I I would to
request you brothers and sisters, please
give us five minutes of your time. Even
if you do not donate the donation of
your time is definitely is really the
tremendous reward from Allah subhana wa
t'ala. So please give us few minutes. I
just wanted to let you know that we are
going to raise funds today for our
masid. Alhamdulillah Alam all the
facility that this you see here all the
activities all this is done supported
and contributed by you brothers and
sisters. You have done a marvelous job
over the years and we're going to ask
again our today the run rate right now
for the masjid is 25,000 a month which
is about our budget is 300,000 so
monthly is $25,000
and if you really think about this this
includes all the utilities which
includes the Rahma Academy utilities
also so whatever you're contributing to
donating today is going to be also
helping that Rahma Academy but also
So the the payroll, the all the taxes,
the things that we do to make sure the
maintenance and stuff is every bit of
that is really managed and controlled
the best we can. So without any further
delay, I would to ask you and
and she is going to help me with that.
Who is going to donate the first
$10,000?
Takabir Takir. Dr. Come on, tech.